we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
why don't we go oh I don't know if that
will allow it I'll go to the 7 5 7 area
code next caller from 757 please tell us
who are you and what's on your mind
today hello are you doing um I'm
actually a 17 year old viewer on your
channel on YouTube okay and I am
actually I actually enjoy watching your
channel because by me being 17 and a box
into the world and being a senior in
high school coming up this year
it's very informing to me and that
allows me to know what's going on in the
world and I appreciate that and like how
you handle your views and everything is
this outstanding you know you never
break character or act immature you
don't do anything to cause a lot of
character let me tell you up stir right
right but yeah I just wanted to call and
tell you that I think you're doing an
amazing job with your channel and how
you're running everything is really
amazing and I also had a question please
that was a question of a statement to me
about I don't really remember her name
but the lady holding up the mannequin
had a Donald Trump yes kind of my
personal opinion yeah yeah my personal
opinion on that that was kind of out of
character for her to do something like
that
I believe if you have a problem with the
president not saying I'm with or against
them just saying in general you know you
can voice your opinion in a less
disturbing way now as we can all clearly
see without her he's been trying to come
back and cover it up she has a problem
with him now there are ways to handle
things being an adult which she should
know even I know that but with the
situation like that it should have never
been carry it out like that now are you
know a lot of people don't like our
president but you know everybody had a
chance to vote and we all stood that
chance to vote and the outcome became
the outcome there are certain ways and
certain things to do to go about
handling the situation without having
be so graphic in just unnecessary like
that right but let me ask you this
question okay and what was your name by
the way hi Diggs okay
here's the question were you more
offended by Kathy Griffin holding up a
doll's head or by the fact that Trump
pulled us out of the Paris climate
Accords within hours of that incident
happening which is now making the United
States the laughingstock of the world
and a negative force on saving the
environment like which one offended you
more I would say by him making us the
lacking stock right so in the grand
scheme of things even if we can say that
what Kathy Griffin did was in poor taste
or we wouldn't have done it or it wasn't
funny or whatever the case may be the
amount of coverage right that received
versus the disaster of leaving the Paris
climate agreement sort of
disproportionate would you agree I agree
yeah okay good all right well we agree
then thanks so much I really appreciate
the call and you know check in with us
again and best of luck as you are you
going to college I plan on going to
college I'm going into my senior year of
high school right now but after and on
about it's very nice all right well
listen stay in touch let us know what's
going on and I really really appreciate
the call